[Música]
crece la atención entre Perú y Colombia
este sábado la presidenta Dina boluarte
cargo contra su homólogo colombiano
Gustavo Petro y le pidió que se dedique
a gobernar su propio país esto luego de
que el congreso peruano declarara
persona en un grata al jefe de estado
colombiano
en el marco de la Cumbre de seguridad de
Múnich el secretario de estado de
Estados Unidos Anthony blinken se reunió
con su homólogo chino huanji y advirtió
que un apoyo material a Rusia tendría
consecuencias Juan dijo que el uso
excesivo de la fuerza por parte de
Washington dañará las relaciones entre
ambas naciones
como Milagros han sido calificados tres
rescates de sobrevivientes turcos del
terremoto cuando han pasado más de 290
horas y la cifra de fallecidos en
conjunto con Siria superó los 46.000
en France 24 estamos de vuelta con las
noticias que marcan la jornada soy
Valentina Torres Sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos damos inicio en América
Latina porque crece la atención entre
los gobiernos de Perú y Colombia la
presidenta peruana Dina boluarte cargó
contra Gustavo Petro y le exigió que se
dedique a gobernar su propio país esto
luego de que el congreso peruano
declarara persona en un grata al
mandatario colombiano un fuerte crítico
del manejo de la crisis social en Perú
ampliamos en el informe
la atención entre Perú y Colombia ha
escalado hasta el punto que el viernes
el congreso peruano declaró persona no
ingrata al presidente Gustavo Petro el
punto de la discordia un comentario del
mandatario colombiano criticando la
acción policial peruana en las protestas
contra el gobierno en Perú los policías
marchan como nazis contra su propio
pueblo rompiendo la convención americana
de los Derechos Humanos la medida contra
Petro que ha apoyado al expresidente
Pedro Castillo desde que salió del Poder
y no ha reconocido a fuerte como
presidenta prohíbe el presidente de
izquierdas volver a pisar Perú e implica
un quiebre en las relaciones bilaterales
entre Colombia y Perú yo desde acá le
digo al señor Petro que yo que se
dedique a gobernar Colombia que también
sus calles están llenando de protestas y
que nos deje a nosotros los peruanos
resolver las nuestras no obstante pese
al enfado de Lima el presidente
colombiano no ha sido el único que ha
señalado comportamiento sin apropiados
por parte de la policía peruana en el
marco de las manifestaciones que exigen
elecciones anticipadas y la división de
Dina boluarte en el país andino amnistía
internacional acusó a las autoridades de
hacer un uso ilegítimo de armas contra
civiles
con un sesgo racista y clasista
especialmente contra los indígenas el
número de muertes arbitrarias por la
represión estatal se encuentra
concentrado de manera desproporcionada
en regiones con población
mayoritariamente de pueblos indígenas
por el mismo motivo el gobierno de Perú
también ha tenido tensiones con otros
países de la región como México o
Bolivia
en la región de sucumbíos en plena selva
amazónica ecuatoriana todavía quedan los
vestigios de la actividad petrolera de
tres décadas de la empresa
estadounidense Texaco algunos pozos
cerraron y empezó una ardua batalla
judicial por la limpieza de la zona pero
en la actualidad activista así
comunidades locales siguen reclamando
justicia ambiental luego de verse
afectados por la contaminación y la
pobreza más detalles en el siguiente
informe
oro verde por oro negro en pleno corazón
de la amazonía ecuatoriana la extracción
de petróleo por parte de la empresa
estadounidense Texaco durante décadas
cambió la vista para siempre algunos de
los más de 300 pozos ya cerraron pero el
paisaje todavía está lleno de oleoductos
camiones cisterna y refinerías Texaco lo
que hizo fue aquí en la amazonía
ecuatoriana causar un desastre ambiental
por su ambición económica sin respetar
la vida de quienes vivimos acá para los
habitantes de la región así como para
los expertos la industria petrolera en
la zona ha sido sinónimo de pobreza y
contaminación llegándose a verter unos
60 millones de litros de líquidos
nocivos durante la época de actividad lo
que terminó afectando a la salud de
campesinos e indígenas que habitan en la
zona existe un 130% más de desarrollo de
cáncer un 111% más de infertilidad y un
150% más de abortos la pelea judicial de
más de 30 años para asumir
responsabilidades del desastre natural
terminó involucrando a altos tribunales
internacionales pero todavía hoy no hay
solución para las comunidades locales
que apelan a la concienciación y a no
dejar en la lucha Cuál es la esperanza
la lucha social entender el rol que
juega la amazonía en el equilibrio del
clima en el mundo y defenderla en
paralelo el gobierno de Guillermo lasso
apostó por redoblar las actividades
petroleras en las zonas en activo con el
objetivo de extraer un millón de
barriles diarios
Hablamos ahora de Brasil porque el
presidente Luis Ignacio Lula se enfrenta
a una problemática compleja y es las
armas de fuego en manos de particulares
antes de que Jair bolsonaro llegara al
poder la cifra era de 1.3 millones al
terminar su mandato el número se acercó
a las tres millones de armas segundos
ong para analizar esta información
conectamos con Dario pignotti analista
político y corresponsal en Brasil de la
agencia italiana ansa Bienvenido a
France 24 Cómo facilitó bolsonaro la
compra de armamento a particulares para
que el número aumentara de esta forma
Buenas noches a través de dos tipos de
medida una por ejemplo era la de
conceder carnets autorizaciones como
cazadores y coleccionadores a personas
que no tenían prácticamente ningún
atributo para ello y ninguna preparación
y segundo liberando el número de
armamentos por ejemplo alguien que se
presente como cazador o coleccionador
puede comprar hasta 15 fusiles por año y
seis mil municiones prácticamente un
arsenal de guerra esto hizo que en
cuatro años de gobierno de bolsonaro el
número de estas personas que se hacen
pasar o que dicen ser cazadores o
coleccionadores es prácticamente igual
al número de policías de todo el país es
decir una sociedad Armada que por lo
demás en su mayoría estos cazadores y
coleccionadores son simpatizantes del
expresidente bueno para nadie es un
secreto la fuerte polarización que
enfrenta Brasil y en este contexto Pues
el elevado número de armas se convierte
en una preocupación que está haciendo
Lula actualmente para enfrentar esta
situación
tomó dos tipos de medidas una una semana
antes de tomar el poder a través de
sugerencias se impidió que sugerencia
que se convirtieron en medidas de
control se sugirió que no pudiera haber
desplazamiento de personas con armas el
día primero de enero de 2023 y luego que
el control de las armas deje de estar
bajo la jurisdicción del ejército como
ustedes saben buena parte de los
miembros de las fuerzas armadas también
son simpatizantes del expresidente
bolsonaro y pasen a jurisdicción de la
Policía Federal Claro que esto todavía
habrá que ver habrá que medir en su
eficacia por lo pronto hace dos días el
supremo tribunal federal y frente a una
apelación de grupos que defienden el
armamentismo dijo que las medidas de
Lula son constitucionales Por lo cual
hay una luz verde para que esta política
de control de las armas avancen decimos
control porque por lo pronto no hay
medidas o no hay muchas medidas que
retiren ese Arsenal del poder civil o de
los civiles que las tienen Bajo su
jurisdicción Bueno y qué tan lucrativo
es el negocio de las armas en Brasil que
tanta oposición puede encontrar el
presidente Lula en esta lucha
igual que ha ocurrido en Estados Unidos
ustedes saben el gobierno del
expresidente bolsonaro tomó como como
referencia como ejemplo varias de las
medidas de poder del gobierno de Donald
Trump el lobby armamentístico en Brasil
es muy poderoso y también el lobby
social y el lobby el lobby legislativo
tanto que no solo hay en el en la cámara
de diputados el bloque de La bala así
llamado compuesto por ex militares y por
policías y ahora surgió un nuevo bloque
parlamentario el de los cazadores y
coleccionadores que son una escena por
tanto si unimos el poder económico y su
capacidad entre comillas de fuego más El
poder legislativo no será Tan sencillo
para el presidente Lula que no cuenta
con un buen con buena presencia con
mayoría ni en la cámara de diputados ni
en el senado
revertir o hacer frente a este poder
insisto un poder legislativo y económico
muy fuerte en favor de estos millones de
aparentes cazadores y coleccionadores
Muchas gracias por su análisis y por
compartirlo con nosotros en France 24
Muchas gracias vamos ahora hasta
Alemania donde se lleva a cabo la
conferencia de seguridad de Munich en el
marco del encuentro el secretario de
estado de Estados Unidos Anthony blinken
se reunió con su homólogo chino One gym
en la reunión blinquen condenó la
violación a la soberanía estadounidense
con el supuesto globo espía le advirtió
Beijing que habrá consecuencias y brinda
apoyo material a Rusia la conferencia ha
girado en torno a Ucrania hacia la
entrega de armamento mientras que en la
ciudad se han registrado manifestaciones
a favor de la paz la Johan tiene los
detalles
dos manos inflables gigantes partiendo
un rifle por la mitad bajo el lema
queremos la paz centenares de personas
se reunieron para protestar al margen de
la conferencia de seguridad de Munich
exigen el fin de las entregas de armas a
ucranio
es Sencillamente importante que no
podamos suministrar armas
permanentemente porque entonces la
guerra no se detiene Cada día que se
suministran armas muere gente de ambos
bandos y estas personas cuentan es
importante entablar negociaciones de paz
ciertos manifestantes afirman que el
dinero invertido en armamento y
belicismo podría emplearse mejor en
iniciativas de paz otros sostienen
carteles pidiendo la salida de Alemania
de la otan y banderas de las regiones
Rebeldes sirias y del kurdistán para
pedir el fin de la venta de armas a
Turquía
nuestro mensaje es que queremos que la
gente se resista a Las crecientes
Guerras que se están librando no solo en
Ucrania sino también en otros países y
que quede realmente claro que el
gobierno alemán no debe continuar con el
armamento con la exportación de armas y
la guerra
la protesta se cruzó con una
manifestación procrania pidiendo también
la paz pero sobre todo ayuda al pueblo
ucraniano de parte de la Unión Europea
en sus pancartas se puede leer Sin armas
no hay protección y dejen de matar a
nuestros hijos
continuamos con información del
terremoto que devastó el sureste de
Turquía y el noroeste de Siria porque ya
son más de 46.000 los fallecidos esto el
tiempo que Los afectados tratan de
sobrevivir tras perderlo todo Samuel
Salgado nos amplía
imágenes de dron muestran la magnitud de
la destrucción al menos 264 mil
apartamentos quedaron destruidos luego
de los devastadores terremotos del 6 de
febrero en Turquía y Siria
sin embargo entre las montañas de
escombros todavía se encuentra vida los
casos son extraordinarios
[Música]
esta familia permaneció 296 horas bajo
los escombros los padres sobrevivieron
pero el niño murió después de su rescate
por deshidratación taja erdem de 17 años
fue rescatado en la ciudad de adillamán
en el sur de Turquía grabó su
experiencia bajo los escombros cuando
pensaba que iba a morir
al otro lado de la frontera en Siria las
operaciones de rescate finalizaron Hace
unos días
Italia y la comunidad europea
respondieron al llamado de auxilio de
bachata esto ha permitido la actuación
conjunta del bloque en la entrega de
ayuda humanitaria a pesar de las
sanciones internacionales que pesan
sobre el régimen sirio
no es momento de hablar de política
debemos unirnos
Estados Unidos país que no reconoce al
régimen de vallar al asad prometió 85
millones de dólares en ayuda tanto a
Turquía como a Siria a través del
programa said Corea del Norte le dan su
misil balístico was son 15 el segundo
con mayor alcance de esta nación el
aparato se estrelló en la zona económica
marítima japonesa según Tokio que
denunció una nueva provocación de pianya
sobre la isla japonesa de okido una bola
de fuego atravesó el cielo difundidas
por la televisión japonesa estas
imágenes serían las de un misil
disparado el sábado por Correa del Norte
antes Corea del Sur dio la alerta el
anuncio fue seguido por viajeros en la
estación de tren de seúl El misil
recorrió 900 kilómetros antes de
estrellarse en la zona económica
exclusiva de Japón según Tokio
estos disparos son una provocación a la
comunidad internacional en su conjunto y
naturalmente hemos protestado
enérgicamente
entonces
la seguridad del pueblo japonés es lo
más importante antes que cualquier otra
cosa
las autoridades japonesas afirman que se
trataba de un misil balístico
intercontinental según los expertos
Unión podría haber querido probar un
misil de combustible sólido una
tecnología que el régimen norcoreano
Busca dominar
es más fácil de almacenar y más difícil
de detectar desde noviembre de 2022 este
es el segundo misil norcoreano que cae
en la zona económica exclusiva japonesa
en los últimos meses la tensión ha
aumentado en la región al intensificarse
los lanzamientos de prueba de Corea del
Norte y como represalia los ejercicios
militares conjuntos entre seúl y Estados
Unidos de hecho los disparos de prueba
del sábado se producen pocos días antes
del inicio de ejercicios simulados entre
los dos aliados para prepararse ante un
posible ataque nuclear de Unión en otro
signo de escalada las autoridades
surcoreanas calificaron el jueves a su
vecino de enemigo un término que no
utilizaban Desde hacía seis años
viendo el informativo volvemos en breve
[Música]